So SLI with Black I mean
I've had it before or I think so,
well let's try to play a
slightly more
unusual variant here, it
looks strange but it's
actually quite solid for
Black,
yes White's problem is now
the strange knight  he
somehow doesn't find good squares
and
he doesn't get to E4 well in the
position
yes
h of course looks very weak here
on the white
squares that could
really become a problem at some point for the
question of where it belongs here,
maybe again later  back no, well
first of all
he can do that here, of course,
so I can
somehow take advantage of this strange constellation
here
if the knight were a little better
then B5 would be an
idea, well I'll bring it
back again, I was thinking about E8 D6 maybe
because it's coming  yes now in the
constellation it's not really possible to
continue
like this now we can nibble a
little bit
B5 I covered it with
the
knight like this
so if I now
take
like this and now even B5 is that an idea
then with the idea then like this rook  A4 and so on
C6 is getting weak ne C6 is getting very weak
from
me but he really has a really
bad runner no well that's how it's
interesting I don't know if it's a good thing
so
here you could theoretically well
come on better not just thought of that
Knight D5 yes but
yes he really wants to go in there
I understand that too otherwise he does
n't have a big plan so we'll take away for now
so ah yes maybe I want to go
to C5 but the3 then go to C5
so yes he can go to D6 but for
now also  not so
bad so knight A6
covers he could also move rook
A4 again
knight C6 I can now
still play queen D6 e.g. or queen D7 no
but
lady D6 doesn't have a tempo for now
h very
interesting what should I know now play
knight
F4 maybe  yes knight F4
D3
interesting would like to take B5
just yes
not a stupid
idea well we can still cover like this so W
now rook C1 is now playing Dr of course
here so
win pieces W I move it away it has a
good space for the
knight I have no idea yes it looks a
bit  hairy from
somehow
yes I so I
still don't see anything great for him but it seems
a bit
uncomfortable
so knight A6 you can do now
probably wouldn't clarify something on
something the
position here ne then B5 takes and then
B4
beats
h yes  you can
now try Springer E8
yes to
cover it is a bit risky
no
yes I don't know if everything
I've done here is that good,
even if I still don't
see anything concrete so okay it's going
back but it also reliably covers
B4
So I want Queen
B6,
so now I'm going to attack C5. I mean,
I don't know if it's really hanging, because
one of
could also be a pretty
decent quality sacrifice if he
just leaves it there, but I might
just want to play Knight A6, but it
goes away like that  here
knight
C5 I can
beat C6
so
time so C7 again
cover well now he wants to
get to the kingside I'll exchange my rook
if he lets me
no he
won't do
that but now knight now now
I've got myself a knight C5
put it in I sppel oh oh oh how
unpleasant that's
stupid I somehow
managed that stupidly
yes okay I have to give Jellyfish maybe it's
not that terrible in
the
position I think time is my
bigger enemy
here oh knight
C6 oh no how unnecessary how
unnecessary  oh
yes, black
resign,
well that was interesting, but was it good?
Maybe you
just have to play a simple game here: knight
A6 rook B5 turmchl B4
tur B4 queen B4 and the position is
probably somehow the same yes, so at most the
same for white if at all
Black is a bit better, and
not always that complicated, and then
I somehow managed to position myself so
awkwardly.
A6 was of course
really
stupid, stupid,
and of course the position is
still bad